في الخبر الاوكراني ايضا الامريكيه تشير
الى اختلاف في الرؤى بين البنتاجون
والاداره الامريكيه حول الاستراتيجيه
المقبله في اوكرانيا والتي يجب اتباعها في
هذا الصدد نستقبل معنا زميل خالد الغرابلي
محرر شؤون الدوليه في فرانس 24
ذهاب الى المفاوضات ووقف الحرب لماذا هذا
هذه الوصيه في هذا الوقت
لان القياده العسكريه في الولايات المتحده
همم ترى من الناحيه العسكريه انا الجيش
الاوكراني حقق ما يمكن ان يحققه على الارض
بشكل مناسب قبل الشتاء بكلمات اخرى هذا
اقصى ما يمكن ان يحققه على الارض قبل فصل
الشتاء الذي بدا عمليا من الذي همم ادلى
بهذه التصريحات رئيس الاركان مارك ميلي
عندما يخرج رئيس الاركان رمضان ليدلي بمثل
هذه التصريحات واجهه الى القياده السياسيه
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان الرجل الذي يعلم
تمام المعرفه
قدرات الجيش الاوكرانيه وما يملكه من
تسليح وخطط التسليح التي سيحصل عليها جيش
الاوكراني لاحقا ويعلم ايضا من خلال
الاستخبارات تحركات الجيش الروسي ولديه
صور الاقمار الصناعيه لهما فعله جنود
الروس في اوكرانيا وهو كرجل عسكري يستطيع
ان يتوقع سيناريوهات المعركه في المرحله
المقبله وصل الى خلاصه انه وصلنا الان الى
مرحله مع بدايه الشتاء الذي بدا بالفعل
انه يجب لن يكون هناك تغيير كبير على
الارض
ويجب ان تتحرك الامور ربما باتجاه
المفاوضات قد يكون هناك حصد لما تم فعله
على الارض لماذا لانه عرض في هذا الاجتماع
صور للقوات الروسيه في هذه المنطقه وهي
تقوم بحفر الخنادق وتستعد لفصل الشتاء
بكلمات اخرى وهو يقول الروس عندما انسحبوا
هم انسحبوا يدعموا دفاعاتهم للمرحله
المقبله وسندخل مرحله الشتاء وهذا ربما
يذكرنا بما حدث ايام الحرب العالميه
الثانيه حرب الخنادق التي تستمر له شهور
طويله لا يتغير الكثير على الارض لكن يكون
هناك الكثير من الضحيه والكثير من الانفاق
العسكري وبالتالي همم خساره بدون تحقيق
الكثير على الارض ومن هنا ينصح بان يتم
التوجه الى طاوله مما يقوله رئيس الاركان
نستطيع ان نفهم الى حد ما لماذا انسحب
الروس
لماذا هذا السؤال مهم لانه كثره الاقاويل
على عن سبب الانسحاب ولم يعرب بدقه حمى
الرز قالوا انه نريد ان نحافظ على جنودنا
لماذا يعني كيف نفهم ذلك ننظر الى الخارطه
اولا لابد ان نفرق من اقليم خيرسون او
منطقه خرسون بهذه المنطقه كما هو مكتوب
هذا اللون همم خرسون
والمناطق الزرقاء هي ايضا جزء من اقليم
خرسون وهذه هي المنطقه التي كان يتواجد
فيها الجنود الرتبه معنى الروس لم يكن
قدسيطر على كل اقليم كرسون هنا لكن كان
يسيطر على هذه المنطقه وعبر نهر برو وسيطر
على هذه المنطقه والحديث عن انسحاب الان
ليس من كل الاقليم ولكن فقط العوده
الانتقال من هذه الضفه من نهر برو الى هذه
الضفه لماذا يريدون الانتقال من هذه الضفه
لهذا الضفه لان الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لدى
الاوكرانيين على ماذا كانت تعتمد على
استهداف
وسائل الدعم وطرق الدعم التي تنقل الاسلحه
والمعدات والجنود الى القوات الروسيه
الالاف من الجنود الروس في هذه المنطقه
وهذا عمليه ماذا يعني انه دخول فصل الشتاء
خطوط الامداد التي هي تمر عن طريق هذا
النهر هي عباره عن عبارات وجسور عندما يتم
استهداف العبارات والجسور وتدخل ظروف
الشتاء القارس بدا يحدث تصبح هذه القوات
في هذا المنطقه كما لو كانت قوه محاصره
وتستنزف عمليا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
ومن هنا قرر الروس الانتقال الى الجهه
الاخرى همم حفر الخنادق تدعيم ال- ال- ال-
ال- القواعد الدفاعيه هنا وبالتالي الحفاظ
على خطوط الامداد مفتوحه وان اراد
الاوكرانيين ان يتقدموا سيجدون العائق
المائي وسيكون ارضا عرضا للمدفعيه
والصواريخ الروسيه ان كانوا هم يعبرون او
حتى في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي من يصلح لهم
العوده هنا ليس انتصارا كما قدمه
الاوكرانيون ولكنهم انسحابون استراتيجي
هذا ما تقوله صحيح انسحاب لمصلحه الجنود
الروس لكن يبقى السؤال ان كان الجيش
الروسي بما هو معروف عنه بقوته لماذا يضطر
في النهايه الى ان يكون خطوط الامداد
ضعيفه بهذا الشكل ويكون قوته هنا بهذا
الضعف هو لو بالقوه المناسبه كلثاني قوه
عسكريه في العالم كان من المفروض ان ربما
تقدم حتى مما بعد خرسون لكن ان يصل قدرات
الجيش الروسي الى ان يضطر الى التراجع عن
منطقه يعتبرها اراد الروسيه ليحافظ على
قوته وسيطرته على الارض هذا في طبعا تراجع
همم لقدره او دليل عن الجيش الروسي ليس
بالقوه التي يتحدث عنها طيب هذه هي هذا
المشهد كما يصوره العسكريون
والاستراتيجيون ماذا الان عن الرؤيا
السياسيه الامريكيه مستشار همم بعيدا لا
يميلون الى اتباع نصيحه همم
نيو تايمز في هذا الاجتماع قالوا انهم لا
يريدون ان يظهر بمظهر من يضغط على
الاوكرانيين لكي يتنازلوا عن اراضي في اي
مفاوضات نقولها مع جانب الروسي
والجانبين ان كان الروس او الاوكرانيين
غير مستعدين الان في المفاوضات ويريدون ان
يتركوا يتركوا المجال على الارض للقوات
العسكريه لتغير من الامور حتى تجني مكاسب
اكبر على ثوره امراض هذا ما يقال لكن
حقيقه الامر تبدو القياده الامريكيه
سياسيه في تخبط غير واضحه الامور تماما
لماذا اقول ذلك همم كان موجود في كاف قبل
نحو اسبوع واثناء حديثه مع القياده
الاوكرانيه دعى
الى ان يفكر في السلام العادل ان كان
الامور واضحه بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
انه يجب الاستمرار في المعارك لماذا يدعو
الى التفكير في السلامه العادل ايضا طرح
عليه السؤال في ما يخص مستقبل الامور في
اوكرانيا قال يبقى ان ننتظر لنرى حكم
الاوكرانيين ان كانوا والدين لتقديم
تنازلات لروس ام لا هذا معناه ان فكره ال-
ال- الجلوس الى طاوله المفردات همم موجوده
وحتى فكره تقديم تنازلات الى جانب الروسي
موجوده ماذا نفهم من تناقض هذه التصريحات
الاداره الامريكيه ليس لديها رؤيه واضحه
فكيف ستفعل مع الروس لماذا
العسكريون قالوها صراحه نريد اضعاف الجانب
الروسي والاضاف يعني استمرار الحرب لكن
مشكله الامريكيين انهم لا يستبعدون ان
يقوم بوتين همم باستخدام السلاح النووي
حتى لو كانت تكتيكي لانهم بيعرفون ان هذا
الرجل لن يقبل ان يبدو انه ان هذا ما في
هذا الحرب امام شعبه وبالتالي في لحظه ان
استمرت الخسائر العسكريه قد يستخدم السلاح
النووي اذا كيف يمكن
استنزاف في روسيا بدون ان يصل الى حد
استخدام السلاح النووي الخط ضعيف جدا
المنطقه الرماديه ضعيفه جدا وبالتالي هناك
الكثير من الخطوره بالاضافه لانها
الاوروبيين وسامح ان الرئيس الفرنسي يدعو
الاوكرانيين يجلس ولا طاوله المفاوضات
يعني حلفاء الجانب الامريكي يريدون
التفاوض وهم يعلمون انه في نهايه الامر لن
يكون هناك حل عسكري وانما حاله تفاضليه
لكن اختيار التوقيت للوصول الى هذا حاله
تفاضلي يبدو ان يضر على الملكيه لم تصل
الى تحديد التوقيت بشكل طبيعي شكرا لك يا
خالد الغراب للرئيس الفرنسي الذي يعني
عندما قال هذا الكلام جوبيها بنقد شديد
غرب وشرقا شكرا لك خالد الغراب لي محرر
الشؤون الدوليه فيفا